prenez un jeu simple et populaire des
deux couleurs quelques pièces et la
suite nous est racontée par marie et
puis tout le monde choisit un petit
colère comme les enfants comme on est à
l'école et puis jean vallée de l'escou
lorient jean di giovanni sapin ce jeu
leurs trappes vous cette façon de
perpétuer la tradition
oui trimane divertir occupé informé en
attendant les yoles telle est la
vocation de cet espace dédié et la
publicité y occupe une place de premier
choix
il y a bien entendu les grandes
entreprises et les plus modestes qui
cherche à gagner en notoriété
cette jeune entreprise a elle aussi fait
le pari du jeu cadeaux avec un système
de poids à condition de faire preuve de
beaucoup de patience et donc nous avons
là cette année le jeu du fakir vous
lancez un petit palais dans un
labyrinthe de clouer à l'arrivée vous
avez d un total de points voyez le monde
dia on doit reconnaître qu'on a un franc
succès un franc succès qui s'explique
également par un investissement
conséquent de l'entreprise ces lots ont
coûté près de 35000 euros
c'est un pari gagnant pour nous
je pense que c'est un très bon
investissement csr on s'est fait
connaître
quand même comme ça par les viols les
gens de la poule il ya beaucoup de gens
qui à force de faire des villes non
c'est très bon pour nous le public quant
à lui est ravi
alors j'aime clé en combien de points là
là je voudrais faire vérifier at-elle
1200 points pointent vers le bas
beaucoup comme un point vous manque
alors qu'à 400 points
comment vous allez faire
je vais faire jusqu'à l'arrivée de
laguiole de la bei j'ai déjà récupéré
mon barbecue
j'ai récupéré desservir donc maintenant
je joue voulait les timbales et voilà
cela de du jeu que s'il vous plaît dans
cette ambiance le fait que ça occupe
en attendant l'arrivée ce qui
m'intéresse c'est de participer à tous
les stands des cadeaux au maquillage il
n'y a que quelques pas à faire en phase
donc cet autre entreprise propose une
pause en couleurs entre son prénom et sa
yole favorite
chacun y trouve son compte pour se faire
connaître